let me ask you about that this was more  on the Republican side a kerfuffle or  however you want to describe it about  the Melania Trump and Heidi Cruz that  came out with the attention that was  being paid to two wives and spouses do  you think that is fair yeah you know our  spouses fair game in this I don't think  families are fair game i think that  spouses put themselves out there in a  supportive role we're not playing  partisan politics to criticize people as  they did as Trump did for Heidi Cruz  that for her looks that's ridiculous  first off she's a very nice-looking  woman I mean this but beyond that that  it's just not nice to take personal  attacks against anybody let alone the  spouse's I think I think it's fine to  ask questions of them if we if we are  here you can ask questions